hi my name is Billy Eichner and I feel
over the goddamn Moon about being Conan
O'Brien's friend that's the angriest
anyone's ever said that how you feeling
today oh but the goddamn Moon I am so
[ __ ] grateful
thanks for throwing me a bow
thanks world thank you thank you for
letting me on your podcast
what an honor you made it you made it
past the Velvet Rope onto my podcast
exactly what an exclusive group
foreign
it's funny because just before we
started taping I was like oh yeah BJ
Novak was here yesterday who you know I
I love he's great and and then I just
started attacking you I said you sir no
BJ no fat yes look I'm an aspiring BJ no
exactly I'm a BJ Novak for the little
man
you know what's so funny uh Billy first
of all I adore you and I'm so thrilled
that you're here thanks for coming on uh
on on the podcast it's so funny because
I'm you know I was like a good boy doing
my research today not that I have to
because I know you so well and I've been
a fan for so long then this little
tidbit comes across my page as I'm
scanning through info on you and bio
stuff that you were a waiter for a while
and I was thinking
you as a waiter would terrify the [ __ ]
out of me I was a terrible waiter
and I think so yeah I didn't last long
um I waited tables in New York uh when I
was a struggling act or you know I a lot
of my friends were doing that so they
got me a job waiting tables they were
all pretty good at it and I was terrible
and then I remember the manager after
one of my first training days I sat down
at the bar and I was just my brain was
fried I have so much respect for waiters
especially I mean the cus I'm a native
New Yorker I love New York more than
anything but we can be awful
you know especially you know the rich
ones and uh I mean that's just the truth
I experienced it and then I so I sat
down at the bar at the end of the day
and the manager came up to me this very
nice young woman and she said
you had a really hard day huh you know
because she saw I was struggling yeah
yeah and I did and I quickly kind of
pivoted to being a bartender which was a
much better job well that's the thing is
a surly bartender there's something cool
and edgy about a surly bartender and
it makes sense to me because you're
asking for your alcohol and if they're
they treat you badly it somehow makes
sense to me yeah well here's your
alcohol the bartender the bartender has
power yes you know like people want that
drink there's only one of you or two of
you so they want your attention it's
kind of it's a much sexier job yes you
know yes Tom Cruise and cocktail I was
just thinking cocktail because we're the
same generation and also all I think
about is that movie Cocktail all the
time you know what was also from that
movie Cocktail Kokomo yes by the Beach
Boys yeah Gonna Take It Fast and then
we'll take it slow
that's where we wanna go
way down
oh no
I think most of the most Turkish boys
are Maga yeah Beach Boys are proud boys
would be a fun game to play now
he plays the drums The Beach Boys it's
the only rock group I've ever gone to
see where they were okay they all came
out and they were wearing blue blazers
you've ever seen is the Beach Boys
and they weren't and I never did go see
them uh you know I was painting a little
bit of a word picture there I see but
um yeah I think you as a waiter I just
find if you came up to my table
and said what do you want to hear about
the specials do you want to hear about
them I'd be I'd be so intimidated I'd
say you just tell us what we're gonna
eat and then I'm gonna leave the money
and not even eat it what do you want a
beverage you [ __ ] [ __ ]
what do you need an extra spoon go [ __ ]
yourself